[Captions by Y Translator]
We've done some fun stuff
with dry ice in the past.
Today, we're going to kind
of push that to a limit,
and see what happens
if we drop a lot of dry ice
into some very hot water.
[Music]
We got a common request
from YouTube user Sagar Parajuli
asking us to boil
dry ice plzzzz.
Plzz.
To start out, we want to take
a look at the difference
between putting dry ice
in room temperature water
and boiling hot water.
See if we get
a different result.
Here's the basic idea.
We'll take dry ice and water,
and see what gives
us the best reaction,
and then scale that up.
Let's put in there
for 30 minutes.
Just like 30.
Just until it boils over,
and then we take it out.
30.
Has your microwave had a bowl
of water explode inside it?
Calli is going to show you
how to fix that,
because I don't know.
Apparently, she's
microwave expert.
So the first thing you want
to do is go to the store
that sell microwaves.
Pick one up...
And then you're done.
Yeah, that's it.
That's how you fix
your microwave guys.
We're really good at this.
[Music]
Trying to just get two pieces
that are kind of the same.
That's pretty close.
All right, you take one.
>> Got it.
>> I'll take one.
So this one is
super boiling hot,
and this one is just tap water.
Hot...
Not hot..
Room temperature.
That's the word.
All right, so we're going to drop
these in the count of three,
and see if there's a difference.
1, 2, 3.
Gee, I wonder what
the difference is.
There's this, there's a bit
of a difference here.
So though dry ice
and room temperature water,
it definitely still produces
vapor as you can see.
So, the hot water
is making the dry ice
is actually sublimate
faster in this one.
But you're still getting
bubbles in room temperature.
You're actually
getting more bubbles.
So those were about
the same size,
and now from a hot water,
we just have this tiny little chip
floating around the surfaces,
which I'm trying to grab
but it's running away from me.
Come here you.
So the cold water
definitely last longer.
That's our dry ice left there.
And that's how dry ice left
from the colder water.
So we are going
through our dry ice much faster
with the hot water,
and that entertaining [inaudible]
Just vibrating on the counter.
So boiling hot water
definitely gets you
a lot more of a reaction.
That's good.
There's one other thing
I want to test though,
and that is the surface area
of the dry ice going
into hot water.
Will the same quantity of dry
ice give us a bigger reaction
if we crush it up into powder,
or is it better
as a single block?
Let's find out.
Okay, these two chunks of dry
ice are about the same size.
Now, I'm going to chop
one of them up,
and just break it up
until it's a really fine powder,
and the other one going
to leave as a chunk.
[Music]
Nope.
It was so angry about that.
No, don't do that.
3, 2, 1.
[Music]
That is just cool.
So right at the
very very beginning,
this had just a huge plume,
and so quickly, it dissipated.
And now, we've just got
like this little low
bubbling come out of it.
Yeah, but look at the way
it expands across the counter.
>> It's already almost gone too.
I don't know I kind of--
Like I did, I did like
the sudden explosive bit,
but I'm liking
how that just keeps pouring
stuff out more and more.
So maybe what we
need to do is both.
Just have like a large chunk,
and then also
some powder for just
some extra explosiveness right
at the very beginning.
But I think we also need
to start scaling this up,
and you may notice there's
a few sizes of pots here.
Which one are we going with?
I think we need to do...
Let's do them in order.
Let's do...
Small, medium, large.
[Music]
That's a terrible noise.
Okay, we've got our small pot.
That's reached a rolling boil,
and here we've got a good-sized
chunk of dry ice as well,
as some smaller chunks,
and even some powdered bits
down at the bottom.
We're just going to pour all
of that in at once,
and see what kind
of explosive reaction we get.
Whenever you're ready.
[Music]
It actually threw out
a little bit of water with it.
Oh, good.
Boiling water everywhere.
Yeah.
That's actually warm.
That's really cool.
Oh, yeah.
The vapors coming
off of this is quite warm.
It's really hard to put
dry as vapor in your mouth,
because for one thing it's...
Like it's fizzy.
Like it makes your mouth fizzy.
But your body doesn't want
to breathe it in.
So it's going to try
and make you cough.
Like that.
Yeah, it gets into your throat
at all, it's just...
Your body's just like,
no, don't breathe this in.
You die from this.
This is the opposite
of everything we wanted.
[Music]
There we go.
We're going to want to stand
back a little farther
for the bigger...
For the bigger pot.
Yeah, we are.
That started throwing drops
of water kind of right away.
I want to know
if the water is cool
enough to touch.
Nope.
It's very...
It's very warm water.
>> It's like hot tub.
>> It has definitely cool down a lot.
Should we chop up a bunch more?
Yes.
That was really cool to watch.
The little mini explosion
and how much vapor we got,
but we weren't technically
boiling the dry ice.
Not yet.
We put the dry ice
into boiled water.
Let's try actually boiling it.
Let's see what it does.
All right, we got
more water boiling on the stove.
We'll see if it's any different
if we actually leave it
in the boiling water.
Oh good.
It does that.
So that's pretty much the same
reaction we're getting before.
So yeah, it's just
more consistent with
what we had before.
I think it...
Yeah, it's probably
slowing down,
or it's probably staying hot
a little bit longer,
not cooling down quite as fast.
Although, you can see we already
have a different reaction.
We're no longer getting
that pillar rising
up to the ceiling.
So I think that means
that the dry ice
is winning the fight
between hot and cold here.
So the water itself probably
isn't even boiling anymore.
That's a good way to test it.
It's not.
Yeah, when I blow all the vapor
out of the way, I can see
that there is bubbling right
off of the chunk of dry ice,
but it's not boiling
the water anymore.
Even though we have this stove
turned as high as it goes.
So here it is,
the piece of dry ice
that has been boiling.
And I would say
that it looks pretty much just
like what it looked like
before it went in,
except now, it's
a little bit smaller.
Not really any more brittle.
[Music]
So, boiling dry ice,
I mean you get
a cool explosive effect
when it lands
in the boiling water.
But as soon as it cools down,
you're back to normal dry ice.
So I think with our
scaled up experiments,
we will not leave things
on the stove just
because it's splashed water out
with both of the tests
we've done so far,
and I think we want to avoid
splashing too much water
on the appliance and stuff.
So we're going to take
our boiling water,
and same as we did
with our first experiment,
we're gonna take
them off the stove,
put them on the hot pad,
and then put the dry
ice in over here.
[Music]
3, 2, 1.
Oh, that is everywhere.
[Music]
Holy cow.
Cal, can you see me?
No.
Where are you?
Try and blow smoke ring in this.
I did.
Did you see it?
Yes.
Good job.
[Music]
It's so warm and fizzy.
We got the same explosion
that we had before
with the big chunks,
but now, we're just
at that rolling sort of...
Filling, filling the
room with vapor.
Kind of like the small chunks did.
And we should make sure
that we have a door open,
because we are filling the room
with carbon dioxide.
We don't want hypoxia.
Is that what
this lightheadedness is?
Ah weird.
[Music]
So I'm thinking
that for our our Mongo pot here,
we should probably
take it outside.
Yeah, and not stand near it.
It's going to be
a lot funnier inside though.
It's true.
[Music]
That's a big old pot
of boiling water.
This is definitely safe.
Yeah.
All right, you take one handle.
I got it.
Ready?
3, 2, 1.
[Music]
I can't see anything yet.
Whoa, that is a weird
sound dampening effect.
Like all the echo is gone.
I had no idea I was going
to take a shower this morning.
I can't see anything.
It's just white.
Mark, can you see us?
I'm going back in.
I'm soaked.
Yeah, that did splash
some boiling water.
That was...
Wow.
The ceiling.
Oh no.
That was definitely a good idea.
There's Mark.
Hey Mark, welcome back.
Only Mark went anywhere.
3, 2, 1.
[Music]
Thank you for
this wonderful idea.
[Music]
There definitely is
a temperature change.
That's insane.
[Music]
Oh my gosh.
Did it--
It actually launched
bit some dry ice too.
No, its-- Have you
seen the floor?
I hadn't been able
to see the floor.
We're soaking wet.
Let's get some towels.
So thanks Sagar
for your suggestion.
Check your inbox,
we are sending you $25
for that shower.
Remember, if you've got any cool
ideas you want to see us try,
let us know down
in the comments,
and if we use your idea
to make a video,
we'll send you 25 bucks.
Guys, that's all for today.
But the fun doesn't end here,
we've got more for you to see.
The box up at the top will take
you directly to our last video,
and you should go
check that out.
The other box will show you
what YouTube thinks
you should be watching next.
And we hit this bomb the middle,
you'll be subscribe
to the channel,
and that way, you'll
never miss out on the fun.
Don't forget to ring that bell,
and we will see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.